c'est une excellente nouvelle écoutez je
vous parle du virus ebola en afrique les
autorités sanitaires américaines
également l'organisation mondiale de la
santé oms a annoncé qu'il ya deux
médicaments qui augmenterait de façon
significative le taux de survie de
patients qui ont le virus de l'ebola
c'est donc un essai clinique qui a été
fait en république démocratique du congo
est vraiment et c'est d'une efficacité
redoutable
on joint le docteur gaby cobain guerre
chercheurs et microbiologiste à
l'université laval dont l'équipe a
participé à la création d'un vaccin
contre le virus ebola docteur kobel
guerre bonjour alors qu'est-ce que vous
peut nous dire concernant ces nouveaux
traitements est ce que ce sont les
traitements qu'on élaborer votre équipe
pas exactement mais c'est le même
exactement le même recette qui est petit
suivi et on veut nous le traitement
qu'on a développés on l'a commencée il
ya plus de 15 ans et donc on utilisait à
l'époque des techniques étaient qui
était pas aussi évolué qu'ils font à
qu'il promène donc on a vraiment mille
et un seul pour les initiés qui a
commencé là toute cette vague de
nouveaux traitements
mais comme une excellente nouvelle qui
va bien plus loin kibo là parce que ça
démontre maintenant cette recette là
justement qui était développé cette
soixante par des nouveaux traitements ça
fonctionne pour le virus ebola est
évidemment mais non ça fonctionne pour
beaucoup plus de maladies infectieuses
et donc de nous donner l'un des nouveaux
outils
ça donne énormément d'espoir en tout cas
quand on regarde la dernière année ça a
été terrible
en république démocratique du congo et
plus de 1700 morts et l'a donc ces deux
traitements lassant sont très
prometteurs est-ce qu'ils sont sous
forme de vaccin tous les deux non
objection qui fait en une seule
injection
et puis tréviers la maladie alors qu'ils
sont parfois même un traitement de gens
qui sont déjà effectifs et donc comme un
pas tous ses films et d'heures après le
côté pourtant sauvé la vie des gens
c'est celle impact sur la communauté
l'église gens maintenant enfin peut voir
que mannequin elite on ma
médicaments et traitements qui veut et
dont orly les motiver à croire autant de
tenter alors qu'à y avoir il y avait
souvent des perceptions qui on allait au
temps d'attenté pour mourir quand il n'y
avait pas vraiment de de traitement la
maladie
ah oui ça va inciter les gens se rendre
plus facilement dans les centres pour se
faire soigner pour obtenir ces
traitements là mais ça va être quand
même tout un défi j'imagine de rendre
les traitements accessibles en afrique
oui tout à fait mais présente un bon il
faut qu'ils sont déjà sur place
donc il y en a pour tous parce qu'il y
en a c'est beaucoup plus facile à
produire le vaccin notamment et il va
qu'il ya des difficultés on produira
suffisamment rapidement comprendre
travaux un nouveau lot mais ces
traitements sont plus faciles il ya
beaucoup plus de capacités au niveau
mondial pour les produits et concernant
le prix c'est quand même accessible
également écouter pour l'écriture que
quand on parle de traitements
expérimentaux comme c'était toujours
plus cher parce que c'est des cds l'eau
qui sont produits à petite échelle mais
oui les coûts de production continue de
sang continue d'étendre on les calcule
puissent bien se souvient avoir dit des
traitements pour un prix non mais tant
mieux c'est très prometteur ça explique
pourquoi il ya tant de sourire dans nos
images de la république démocratique du
congo aujourd'hui docteur comme un gars
merci d'avoir été avec nous merci de
blogo bonne journée sans vent